[Musique]
je suis le commandant mcbride et je
m'efforce de joindre le docteur clifford
mcbride c'est le fils du docteur qui
vous parle
il
j'aimerais te revoir papa
je me souviens qu'on regardait des films
en noir et blanc et que tu avais un
faible pour les comédies musicales
je me faisais travailler mes mates
tu m'a inculqué la valeur du travail
sache que j'ai choisi un métier que tu
approuverait
pour
je consacre ma vie à l'exploration
spatiale et c'est à toi que je le dois
[Musique]
il se produit là haut une crise d'une
ampleur jamais vue
est possible que votre père soit
appliquée mon père est mort
qu'attendez vous de moi au juste
l'exploration n'est pas toujours une
noble entreprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
devant visage et d'hypothèses que ton
père ne veuille pas qu'on le retrouve
[Musique]
et
nous avons un travail à faire
tu prêt je suis prêt